we want to talk with you about
sustainable water first the technical
challenges of water and the definition
of water sustainability the issue of
water supply of the quantity of water
distribution of water efficiency
technology of water itself and the whole
issue of water efficiency because we
waste enormous amounts of water fresh
water on this planet the issue of water
quality pollution organizational
management challenges financial
challenges public policy issues and then
I'll wrap it up definition water is a
finite resource on our planet but it's a
renewable resource there's only so much
water but in effect it does when you use
it it doesn't disappear it doesn't leave
the planet it either evaporates into the
atmosphere and returns in the form of
rain or combines with other chemicals on
the ground and makes it unfit for
consumption as fresh water most of the
water on the planet is actually in the
form of salt water and in fact most of
the planet is covered by salt water so
if we could figure out some way of using
that water and we have actually figured
out the technology it's called
desalinization that would ease elements
of the water crisis but if you think
that water from the catskills is
expensive water from the Atlantic would
be more expensive so the focus tonight
is maintaining the quality and quantity
of water needed for human life and the
support of key of ecosystems and food
systems that rely on water in other
words we require water as a biological
species known as human beings but so do
the plants and animals that make up the
rest of our ecosystem the entire system
requires water it's really a biological
necessity now here at Columbia the head
of our water center is an engineer an
earthen super faculty member named Manu
Lau and he and his colleagues have
divided the
issue into three components I think it's
useful to think about water the way that
Manu thinks about it first is the issue
of access to water so they could that
can be you know sort of water water
everywhere but not a drop to drink
there's plenty of water but you need
infrastructure to store it to treat it
and to deliver it to bring it to
people's homes and to their farms then
there's the problem with damaged or
polluted water the water we may have
those systems but the water that it's
dealing with is so dirty that it has to
be filtered and filtered and filtered
and then there's the issue of water
scarcity resulting from imbalances of
supply and demand in some Geographic
settings people have moved to places
where there isn't any water we call that
las vegas on a pure environmental basis
you would never have a city of that size
in the middle of the desert it's a
little bit crazy nevertheless the
technology exists to carry the water and
filter it and for some reason a a
million some odd people have decided to
move to this place but the original
places people settled for coming from
europe in the united states was in the
places that had these natural resources
particularly water so this definition is
a really succinct analysis of the
component parts of the challenges to
fresh water sustainability access
pollution and Miss distribution of
people and water supplies and the other
thing and this is one of the issues
related to climate change which is why
these issues are interdependent where
today's fresh water is may not be where
it is 50 years from now if the planet
gets three four five degrees warmer so
these things could be changing so let's
talk about the issue of water supply
quantity distribution and efficiency
first is there enough water now the
first thing to think about is
at least seventy percent if not a little
bit more of all the fresh water in the
world goes to farming about twenty
percent is used by industry and only ten
percent gets to the households and this
is if you go to a place like California
most of the water that comes from the
Colorado goes to the farms not to the
cities in fact an emerging discussion is
just that very issue there is
disagreement among experts about the
absolute shortage of water worldwide the
United Nations projects the two-thirds
of the world's population will
experience water stress by 2025 but it's
not that there is not enough water on
the planet for everybody to have enough
it's that the water isn't where the
people are and some of the water is
increasingly polluted and so but but
unlike some of the other absolute
scarcity issues we may face in coming
generations water is a renewable
resource so it's finite but it's
recharged is part of the natural order
of the ecosystem rapidly growing cities
in the developing world are the places
where we're going to see the most water
scarcity about three years ago the UN
reported that more than half of the
planet now lives in cities and in many
of these emerging cities the issue of
water is is is a real problem there is
not enough capital for the
infrastructure so the kinds of
investments we've made here in New York
simply can't be made in other parts of
the world because they don't have the
capital for the infrastructure and the
water is not plentiful nearby so a
project like the Colorado River Project
which is how the western part of the
United States distributes most of its
water are much of its water would simply
be impossible in other parts of the
world generating the capital for water
infrastructure is a worldwide challenge
systems to treat and distribute water
and collect and treat sewage are
essential to public
and Welfare so these packets we talked
about that Procter & Gamble has that
that we distribute in the case study
that we read again a short term solution
the long term solution is we have to
have enough capital to do this now over
the past several decades residents and
businesses in New York City have
directly paid the cost of rapidly rising
water infrastructure the water bills
that people pay in New York City are
growing dramatically on an annual basis
as the system's requirements become more
expensive and more capital more and more
capital is needed to run the water
system and you know it's an interesting
kind of question of people in this
country or don't want to pay more taxes
and they don't like the fact that their
water bills are growing but they see the
connection between the service and and
the fee and so it may be in the long run
a more successful strategy than than a
general tax I mean people pay for things
today that they didn't pay for 50 years
ago water you pay for your television
you know when you have three channels
and rabbit ears it didn't cost you any
money now it costs you a lot of money
people's cable bills are upwards of a
hundred dollars a month in many cases
and in the case of water bills they're
growing at a rapid rate as well so let's
talk about the technology of water
because in the end this is a problem
that is amenable to a technological fix
with enough capital and energy the war
the world's supply of fresh water could
be expanded dramatically each year more
and more of our water is filtered before
we use it and more and more sewage is
treated as well in a sense these are two
parts of the same equation if you have
untreated sewage going into drinking
water then the filtration process is
that much more expensive and extensive
if on the other hand you're treating the
sewage first you have your filtration
problem is less difficult but the
capital requirements run into the
billions
and many millions of dollars are needed
in operation maintance it's not enough
to build the filtration plant you have
to operate it that takes people and fuel
and it takes a new technology and
training to keep the system in good
repair these are not simple of
technologies there and increasingly
they're more complicated because of the
use of of computers and a kind of higher
level filtration than we used to use
arid regions of the world have benefited
from the development of massive water
works projects and like i said before
Phoenix Las Vegas Los Angeles simply
wouldn't have been possible without
water technology these are cities that
are wholly dependent on that but so is
New York you could never have had a city
of this size without the subway system
and without the water system you simply
couldn't have it couldn't have happened
and so the technologies led to this kind
of development now interestingly the
filtration of order for reuse which
you're now seeing where we're taking
sewage sewage treated water retreating
and using it for example to water and to
irrigate golf courses and things like
that and you can use waste water almost
directly on for that kind of views you
don't want to put it on crops but you
know a few golfers you know it's a
different story seriously it's you are
able to use different quality water for
different uses the real interesting
technology is desalinization and the big
problem with the sound ization is the
cost of energy if you reduce the cost of
energy dramatically the cost of
desalinization would go down
dramatically now what we don't know is
then what would be the impact on the
oceans because if you're taking a lot of
water out of the oceans for fresh water
what's left will actually become
different in its chemical composition
than it is today so there's a question
of how much of that you could actually
do if it became mass
but the other potential with cheap
energy would be ever more elaborate
filtration processes so that you
literally separate the h2o physically
from all the contaminants that attach to
it through the use of technology so
that's one solution the other is greater
efficiency one way to sustain the level
of water we need is to increase water
productivity and we're seeing a lot of
work being done on this in a whole
variety of ways one place is the
household with things like you know
low-flow toilets and showers and things
of that sort the other is in agriculture
itself open irrigation ditches lose
water to evaporation that's one
possibility the other is the actual
plants you could actually breed plants
genetically to be more efficient in
their root structure to use water more
efficiently and effectively and so
that's part of what you can do in a lot
of ways a lot of the waste we have has
to do with government subsidies we've
actually encouraged the wasteful use of
water particularly for agriculture
through the way we've subsidized
different kinds of uses and subsidized
irrigation here particularly in the
United States government also often
provides incentives for farmers to only
grow a few specific crops which will
then discourage them from choosing crops
based on local conditions including
water availability so that's another one
of the problems the entire system what's
grown where needs to be rethought with
the idea of water efficiency in mind
crops could be grown where there
sufficient rain for their water needs I
mean sometimes you'll see that a local
economy that where some of the crops
need a lot of water they will grow them
because they can get the irrigation but
they'd be better off growing something
else in that place based on the local
conditions but if the water comes to
them cheap through a
government-subsidized irrigation system
then there's no incentive for them to to
match the plant to the local ecosystem
particularly when some plants and some
foods are subsidized by the government
and some are not
and and I mentioned that household use
of water can be reduced through some
fairly simple technologies we had a
group of students and the environmental
science and policy program that looked
at water use I think was in Abu Dhabi
last year and it turns out the wealthy
folks in that desert country of the
highest status symbol is to have a
fountain in your in your yard in your
courtyard and so all the wealthy people
have these very elaborate waterworks
that lose enormous amounts of water in
fact per capita use of water in this
country is something like 20 or 10 or 20
times what we use here in the United
States and we're not that efficient here
so it's pretty amazing and so there are
clearly some areas where you could get a
water efficiency and as I said before
different uses of water can tolerate
different levels of water quality you
don't need everything to be pure the
water quality for example in the Hudson
is not the kind where you want to just
scoop it out and drink it on the other
hand you could ride a bicycle very close
to it and you're not going to poison you
the way would have when we used to dump
raw sewage directly into the Hudson
River which we haven't done since the
mid-1980s until the mid-1980s we did
that we dumped raw sewage right into the
Hudson it was delightful on the summer a
nice warm summer evening walking along
Riverside Drive you know I mean I often
say there's a reason why Riverside Drive
is a quarter mile from the river you
know and it's the it was the raw sewage
we heard this before when people were
talking about their case but nearly a
billion people do not have access to
drinkable water and over two-and-a-half
billion people don't have access to
improve sanitation this is a large
portion of the planet and infectious
diseases can result from water polluted
by human and animal waste and cancer of
course can result in other diseases from
the toxic chemicals and we're seeing
more and more of this in the developing
world as industrial practices are taking
place that are where the factories are
paying no attention whatsoever to the
effluent coming
out of the factory pipelines and in
rural areas we also have water being
polluted by runoff from farms that have
been treated by herbicides pesticides
and and fertilizer all of which you can
control you can create different
technologies you can be more careful in
how you apply these technologies to the
farm it's not something that has to be
done the way that we're doing now I
think it's really important to
understand that these are important
technologies I mean the fact is when we
talk about food next week if it wasn't
for industrial farming we would all be
starving to death and so we need those
technologies but we need to make them
more sustainable now the ocean is also
increasingly a place a large garbage
pail the what's called marine debris is
growing if you if you have a home as I
do in in Long Beach New York every
morning in the summer they have to go
and rake the beach and clean up all the
stuff that floats in it's just a routine
they don't even think about it anymore
you got guys with these beach rakes and
then you have kids with green garbage
bags and little poles they pick up the
garbage with the all summer long and it
happens all over all over the United
States and here's a nice picture of it
we've seen loss of biodiversity from
overfishing and also the practice of
inadvertently introducing invasive
species in because what happens is you
take water in a ship say in one part of
the world and then you dump the water
out in another part of the world and so
the ecosystems of this other part of the
world are exposed to whatever was living
in that water and in the Great Lakes we
have all sorts of problems with some
very fast-growing clams and other life
that attaches to the piers and so forth
so this issue of water quality is
important and is a growing issue
worldwide
and again a problem that can be solved
with better technology and better
management practices which leads me to
the issue of organizational and
management challenges now the past
several decades have brought substantial
improvement in the technologies of water
supply and sewage treatment when we
built the first sewage treatment plants
in New York City we had what are called
what's called primary treatment which
was essentially a screen that kept the
junk from going into jamaica bay then we
created secondary treatment where we
evaporated some of the contaminants and
then created a sludge and now we have
what's called tertiary treatment where
we apply technology to actually change
the chemical composition of the waste in
fact in New York City we do something
pretty interesting here some of the
older treatment plants in Brooklyn take
their sludge and bring it to the
treatment plant here up in Harlem
because this is a tertiary plant and the
plants that they come from don't treat
it enough to actually be legal under
EPA's regulations for what kind of
effluents who emit into the waterways so
that's just an indication of how this
technology has improved but it's not
just the technology somebody has to know
how to run the stuff people have to have
to use the technology maintain it and so
the use of standard operating procedures
and Trent end and training to make sure
that the sewage treatment plants are
being run correctly is absolutely
success essential the more complex the
technology the more you need to have
people better trained to run these
plants and to understand what's going on
inside of them so as the technology gets
more complicated the management issues
associated with running the technology
gets more complicated preventive
maintenance becomes more and more
important is very undervalued in many
organizations which don't do the little
things to keep the the plan from
collapsing and so it's important to have
not just people that know how to work
this stuff but it's like it looks like
your car you know every 10,000 15
it's got to be brought in to have
routine maintenance done to it and we're
much better at this than we used to be
but people are impatient with putting
the resources into it the politicians
get to cut a ribbon when there's a new
plant but they're not that interested in
funding the routine operation
maintenance because it's not that
glamorous it's not that interesting you
know it certainly doesn't get you a
picture in the local newspaper when when
you're opening the facility in the
developing world and here in the United
States we're seeing the growth of
private contractors to run these plans
which is largely a good thing because
the private sector has the profit motive
to develop technology and because of
their performance will be monitored if
they want to win the next contract it's
a useful technique but there has to be
somebody in the government who knows
enough about the technology to actually
manage it my friend Brent Miller at the
University of Arizona has written about
this management issue he calls it the
hollow state where you basically have
set have taken all the technical
expertise out of the government because
you've contracted out everything and
what remains there's nobody there who
knows enough about the technology to
manage it and so what they need of
course are people from the Masters of
programs here at Columbia to go out and
help run it because you'll have enough
of the science and you'll have enough of
the management that you can combine
those skills and and help run these
contracts for the government so there's
management and organizational challenges
associated with water and then there are
of course finance challenges financing
sustainable water and sewage systems is
a challenge for new york city which has
plenty of money how about the developing
world how are we going to fund this how
are we going to get the capital that's
necessary now what's interesting about
it is because you have to have clean
water it's a necessity of life it's a
primary function that government has to
perform it's very important to have a
financing scheme in New York we created
the water finance authority and water
board which has essentially taken the
management of water into a into an
authority framework that generates its
own revenues when the water board wants
to raise your water bills they don't
have to go to the legislature to get
permission and it's a good thing because
otherwise we probably would be drinking
poison water nevertheless it's a finance
challenge there has to be enough money
available to to make this happen now the
household water bill has become an
established fact of life in the United
States now it sometimes is hidden in
your property tax you may not pay a
water bill in some localities you it
just goes into your property tax but New
York City we have a separate water tax
separate property tax and in other parts
of the country you see it funded in
different ways but it's becoming more
and more an identifiable cost of doing
business and water bills are growing in
1985 the water rate in New York City is
one dollar per 100 cubic feet by 2010 it
was nearly seven dollars so that means
that in a quarter century the water bill
has gone up by seven hundred percent
that's a little bit more than inflation
the price of order is growing as
additional technology and energy is used
to purify it and to transport it we
actually need to develop new processes
that are more cost-effective use less
energy to clean the water but in fact of
anything we're going to need to put more
energy into it because the pollutant
levels are getting higher and so we're
going to have to spend more and more of
our time doing this and as the planet
gets more crowded the infrastructure of
water transport has to be placed in more
densely several places and that can be
expensive put in a water pipe into a
rural area is cheaper than putting a
water pipe into New York City and that
well that you were talking about in
Connecticut that's not going to be as
good a solution as the ground water
becomes contaminated by a heavy heavier
and heavier development in suburban
areas in fact many people have found
that well that you use 25 years ago
can't get you the water you need today
and in fact people are
are getting their water from municipal
systems more and more although fifty
percent of the households in the united
states get their water from groundwater
largely from wells right now it's
becoming that that's a lower number than
it used to be but it's still a very high
number and it's really a reason why we
have to maintain the quality of our
groundwater so it leads to this issue of
public policy water supply is a critical
responsibility of government and the
need for water is not controversial in
other words there are certain services
that government performs that they
simply must perform you have to have
water the skills of the private sector
are needed for water sustainability but
so is the regulation of the water and
the capital formation which requires
public resources we also have to spend
money on the basic research and
development to keep improving this
technology the technology of water
supply water treatment sewage treatment
has been improving some of that is
government spending on RD some of it as
the companies that build these plants
getting better but we have to keep
applying technology to it because the
problem is not going to get easier to
solve it's going to get more difficult
to solve and of course you have to face
equity issues water is a biological
necessity and can't be denied to poor
people you know there's this Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie that takes place on
Mars you know where they get where the
poor people of you know their oxygen
supply is threatened you know the whole
movies about that and you know water is
that's actually how we do water here now
we don't do it to air but we do it to
water so technology has to be
transferred to the developing world and
we have to figure out ways of bringing
water supply to everybody because the
whole issue of poverty eradication of
sustainable development it is not going
to be solved without investment in this
infrastructure now in the
short run you can use these little
pellets from Procter & Gamble but as I
said that's not the long-term solution
so let me conclude first water can be
used more efficiently we should focus
attention on reducing these of watering
agriculture the technology of waste
treatment water filtration and
desalinization can be used to increase
our supply of water but the issue of
cost is not going away we're going to
have to figure out ways of improving
both the technology the use of capital
and the distribution of water it's a
major public policy problem and it needs
to be addressed